[Music]
there's a video that you did
that went a little bit viral and it was
you in a speedo playing the saxophone
and I'm wondering what what where did
this all come from where did this idea
come from why did you post this how are
you doing mentally well if it wasn't a
viral it's gonna be viral now yeah and I
play saxophone when I was younger and
just wanted to see how much I could
remember so I rented it before going to
my in-laws place for Thanksgiving and
when I was there I was trying to learn
some songs I saw that I could play it
still and decided I should play Careless
Whisper and what's helped this thing get
out there even more on the Internet
let's take a quick peek shall we please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you have a fantastic body we've done
Jason just complimented you on your body
I'm gonna go there's this it's Jason the
ESPN Body Issue and you did this photo
shoot I don't even know how cuz this is
not photoshopped or anything and I don't
know how you achieved did you did you
did you poke a hole in the ball with
American Pie
[Applause]
no how did you because I'm gonna try
this later on at home with a golf ball
[Applause]
it's really not funny how did you get
that shot if you want the proper
technique since here it's inside you're
gonna do it later you know uh you just
hold the ball here yeah and he just jump
jump really high and let it go and you
just okay but are you holding it with
your thighs or is it making putt I mean
what's happening there you holding onto
the ball or and it just happened to be
in the right position well you let it go
as you're jumping so it takes flight and
there it go and it's okay how many okay
yeah how many yeah I got some outtakes
on my phone yes yeah yes I wish I'm
right there on camera three there must
have been shots where the ball drift a
little bit and things were revealed
there were plenty of those shots where
the cameraman was a second too early or
too late and it was all my junk and and
the producer came over and said that's
not gonna work and would like to do it
again so I think about 20 tries maybe so
you know just doing jumping jacks yeah
yeah we'll get those photos
[Laughter]
you